[Musique]
il faut que les parisiens à prête à
abandonner leur voiture et utiliser les
transports en commun l'ennui c'est que
ceux qui le programme le plus fort
ne prennent jamais le métro aux heures
de pointe
[Musique]
nous nous trouvons un thé un boulevard
bouton au poste de commande et de
contrôle centralisé du métro de paris
c'est l'envers la partie du décor que
nous ne voyons jamais l'euro à jeu le
plus secret de cette immense machinerie
qu'est le métro d'ici ces techniciens
peuvent contrôler la marge de l'ensemble
du réseau suivre la progression de
n'importe quel ram s'entretenir à tout
moment avec n'importe quel conducteur
quelle que soit la position de sa
machine on les appelle des chefs de
régulation
nul autre micro ondes ne possède un
poste de commande aussi complet pour
établir cette liaison permanente entre
les stations les trains et le poste il a
fallu non seulement faire appel aux
techniques les plus avancées mais aussi
installé un métrage de câbles
souterrains absolument effarant songez
que de son pupitre un chef de régulation
peut établir des itinéraires retardée
aux avancées les trains manoeuvrer à
distance les portillons électrique des
stations ou modifier la distribution du
courant de traction en édifiant ce poste
de commande l'air atp rechercher un
objectif prioritaire
une plus grande régularité permettant
d'augmenter la fréquence des trains et
par conséquent d'accroître la capacité
de transport aux heures d'affluence ce
métro était conçu par bienvenu pour le
compte de la ville de paris comme métro
essentiellement urbain desservant la
ville de paris après tout en 1900 la
zone qui s'étend à l'intérieur des
remparts n'étaient même pas entièrement
construite
or maintenant l'agglomération non
seulement a rempli par email à déborder
les limites de paris intra muros et le
problème par conséquent et d'étendre ce
métro par des prolongements cours à
l'ensemble de la zone agglomérée c'est
au total dix à douze lignes qui seront
prolongées en banlieue tout autour de
paris et voyez l'impact que ça va avoir
un pacte d'une meilleure desserte de la
population qui sera mise sans rupture de
charge en mesure de regagner le centre
de paris un pacte également sur la
circulation automobile qui sera allégée
car tous les gens qui prendront le métro
ce seront des automobiles en moins aux
portes de paris dans les rues de paris
pour convaincre les habitants de la
région parisienne
de donner la préférence aux transports
en commun sans doute convient-il aussi
de réduire la fatigue que procure le
métro et plus particulièrement celle que
causent les escaliers aux personnes
âgées
la ratp qui en est très consciente a mis
en chantier un vaste programme de
construction d'escaliers mécaniques
actuellement le métro de paris installe
dans ses couloirs un escalier mécanique
tous les douze jours mais les escaliers
ne sont pas la seule cause de fête
l'inconfort des trains le bruit la
température qui règne en sont largement
responsables
or le métro de paris utilise sur
certaines de ses lignes des trains qui
date d'avant guerre et dont la
conception est depuis longtemps dépassé
oui
non
sur ce point également la ratp déploie
un effort considérable
trois dates sont à retenir 1951 qui voit
la naissance du métro sur pneumatiques
technique inédite dans le reste du monde
les lignes 11 unis 4 puis 6 ans ont
successivement équipe et 1964 date de
mise au point d'un métro à roues d'acier
comportant les avantages comparables à
ceux du pneumatique
mais ne nécessitant plus aucune
transformation de la voie ferrée
1977 enfin année où seront mises en
service des rames
répondant à des besoins tout nouveau
elles sont destinées essentiellement en
ligne
prolonger en banlieue c'est
ballard prolonger vers créteil
préfecture
jonction de la ligne
invalide porte de vanves et de la ligne
saint lazare je suis fleyhane rend
nécessaire une augmentation du nombre
des voitures sur ces lignes elle rend
nécessaires également des véhicules
capables de stationner et de parcourir
des attestations longue en banlieue nous
avons conçu ce matériel pour cet
objectif de matériel rapide qui puisse
rouler jusqu'à 100 kilomètres à l'heure
ce qui est quand même élevé un matériel
qu'ils soient étanches qu'ils puissent
supporter les intempéries dans
lesquelles les voyageurs soient
correctement
transporté dans clients des qualités de
suspension supérieurs à ce que nous
avons actuellement grâce à l'utilisation
entre la caisse de la voiture et les
bogies d'un coussin d'air qui nous
apportera certainement une très grande
amélioration est en nous efforçant
également de faire porter notre effort
sur l'aménagement intérieur sur la
conception des sièges
nous voudrions avoir des sièges qui est
une allure plus agréable à l'oeil
désagréable également pour le confort
des reins d'usagé l'aération
l'aération également ne pouvons pas les
vitesses aussi grande île
simple comme ça que nous avons écrit
leur s'introduit
le mans paris
ceci nous conduit à des solutions de
ventilation classique
quand il a peur
et potasse 6
tallinn où ils permettent à des
solutions
c'est à dire
confort qui comporterait en est
une réduction de 3 à 4 degrés par
rapport à la température ambiante
st
l'idée du rythme auquel est acceptée
en interview
un là je crois qu'il faut être très
conscient de l'effort considérable
qui est en cours actuellement
nous sommes actuellement
174 à peu près
la moitié du parc du matériel roulant
nous avons encore pour moitié des
voitures qui zappe
en 1992
avoir des voitures d'avant
donc un rythme extrêmement élevé je
crois qu'il est intéressant de citer les
chiffres nous attendons d'ici la fin de
l'année prochaine donc d'ici 15 mois en
gros 500 voitures nouvelles et au cours
de la nuit un parc de combien sur un
parc qui est environ de 3500 voiture
et au cours de l'année 1976 si les
crédits nous le permettent ce sera 500
nouvelles voitures modernes qui se
produiront à nouveau sur le tas dire
mille voitures dire mille voitures en
deux ans et demi approximatifs et 1000
voitures sur 3500 je préfère c'est
considérable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une bonne partie des stations du métro
ont été construites à la belle époque
malgré notre goût aujourd'hui pour la
mode rétro on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
communique la joie de jouer
[Musique]
au fil des ans
la ratp avait apporté par ci par là
quelques modernisations mais depuis peu
elle a pris le mors aux dents
un nouveau style de nation est en train
de naître au il n'a rien de bien
révolutionnaire mais il s'intègre dans
cette notion d'environnement agréable
qui a fait tant de chemin en quelques
années pour superviser ces travaux de
modernisation l'air ratp a créé un
comité de rénovation des stations de
métro
ce comité de rénovation des stations qui
étaient composées d'architectes et de
décorateurs extérieur et qui est et des
alliés avec pas mal de techniciens la
ratp a mis au point un parti de
rénovation qui plus grosse east en gros
à obtenir et d'obtenir une dominante
blanche c'est-à-dire le carrelage et la
[ __ ]
de carreaux blancs et des taches de
couleurs
parlement de l'ue
et par le rock
je mens de l'onu
qui vous permet aussi de mettre en
valeur la route par un éclairage au
sodium nous permet aussi de maintenir
d'avoir la sonorisation et j'ai la
simulation directionnelle des
correspondances et de sortie de même que
la télévision pour les assurent en cours
et de même que le passage de tous les
câbles électriques sur le sort que nous
avons pu installer tous les meubles qui
ont été repensés et planté remis dans
des formes beaucoup plus agréable le
siège par exemple qui ont été étudiées
d'une manière confortable
les corbeilles à papier by ap ap qui est
notamment les 6h ou qui sont qu'un
décret d'une manière agréable et
confortable et de plus en matière de
métallique de façon à être complètement
inapte flamand justement ils ont l'air
d'être en plastique mais lorsqu'on
touche on s'aperçoit que c'est du métal
c'est exactement celle du métal peint il
pourrait nous avons le métal mais une
peinture résistante et nous pensons que
ces sièges ont un grand avenir dans la
métropole hier
peut-être que vous chercher au fond par
cette nouvelle semble nous essayons de
créer
il a agréé à 1
les voyageurs du monde
nous avons essayé le but est de créer un
climat sécurisant qui va sécuriser de
manière à ce que les gens aiment d'être
dans leur station
en fait vous avez à peu près 340
stations dans le métropolitain et nous
avons à peu près 140 stations qui sont
déjà modernisé soit par des carottages
par des modèles session particulière sur
les prolongements dit notamment comme à
gallieni comme un pasteur thomas opéra
eux mais nous avons à peu près 200
stations moderniser et nous et nous
essayons d'établir un programme qui va
nous permettre de faire 15 à 20 stations
par an pourquoi ne pas aller encore plus
loin et ne pas craindre de dire qu'il
existe à tout prendre une poésie du
métro
certes il peut paraître absurde de
parler de poésie à des travailleurs
fatigués qui après une dure journée de
labeur
on encore un long trajet à faire avant
de rentrer chez eux il suffit pourtant
d'ouvrir les yeux et de laisser le
charme aux péris
[Musique]
nous
m
[Musique]